I must admit that there is a tendency
among some Catholics to shy away from
discussing the abuse scandals
and III think this reluctance well it
could have two causes number one it's
it's a horrible and painful thing so
it's easier not to talk about it and
that feeling doesn't justify ignoring
the situation but of course it is an
understandable feeling but number two
I think many Catholics know that the
outrage against the church though
deserved objectively speaking is in many
cases disingenuous you know they know
that a lot of people simply hate the
Catholic Church and they hate Catholics
and they're eager to jump on any
opportunity to criticize it and and and
that they also know that that if they
themselves as Catholics publicly
criticized the church for the sex
scandal lot of other people will join
them in the criticism but the criticism
will quickly morph into an assault on
the church in general and on Catholics
in general I've experienced that myself
this week I can't tell you how many
times as I've been talking about the
scandals I've had people say I agree
Catholics are Satanists and I'm like no
that's not what I'm saying that's not
what I said at all I know you don't
agree I and so there's a lot of that I
think a lot of Catholics are like I
don't want it I don't to be a party I
want to I don't want to end up in part
as part of that conversation
and there's also a double standard
that many of the people who are so
worried about sex abuse in the Catholic
Church are not worried about it anywhere
else even in their own institutions so
it seems like there are people who are
super focused like they're so concerned
about sex abuse of Catholic Church even
though they're not Catholic themselves
they don't send their kids the Catholic
Church they're so worried about that but
the in the institutions where they like
they send their kids to public school or
they go to a different church they're
not focused on it they're they don't
care about that it's only in the
Catholic Church and so I think a lot of
Catholics they see that and then they
say you know I I just even though the
abuse is horrible I don't know I don't
want to talk about it publicly for that
reason now I very much sympathize with
that
inclination but I also feel that it's
it's it's our obligation all the same to
discuss the scandals and to publicly
voice our outrage and disgust and so
that's what I've tried to do this week
no matter the double standards no matter
the hypocrisy is no matter the
anti-catholic bigotry is all that exists
but still the fact remains that these
terrible things have happened are still
happening most likely and and so they
must be exposed and condemned from by
not just people from without but by
people from within when you get to the
point where it's only people from
without criticizing then you've got a
big problem
I think in life you just need to do the
right thing personally and say the right
things and not worry about how other
people are going to react to it or how
they might use it and twist it to their
own benefit you just do the right thing
and let the chips fall where they may I
think that's the only way to approach
life still
I do feel the need to after I you know
I've been focused on this issue a lot
this week been talking about it I've
obviously made my feelings perfectly
clear but I do feel the need to expand
this conversation beyond the Catholic
Church for a moment
because although I expected this
reaction I've still been very disturbed
by much of what I'm hearing and reading
from non-catholics much of the email I
received I've received from non
Catholics especially non-catholic
Christians I would say that easily the
majority of the emails messages from
that latter group have been
extraordinarily prideful and almost
gloating in tone
I cannot tell you how many times I've
I've read this week words to the effect
of I'm so happy that doesn't happen in
my church
now most people aren't saying it exactly
like that although a few people have
told me exactly that verbatim but most
people don't say it like that exactly
but that's the general message of oh
that's a Catholic problem I'm so glad
that's why I'm not Catholic so I don't
have that Catholic problem I've been
informed by many people that the
Catholic Church is abuse problem is
unique and other churches better
churches don't have these issues I've
been told that if somebody wants to
escape the religious sex abuse problem
all they need to do is escape the
Catholic Church
is what I've been told oh you don't say
just leave the Catholic Church and it's
a problem solved because that doesn't
happen anywhere else flee into the arms
of other churches where these same
things simply don't occur because we've
got it figured out it doesn't happen
here for with us it only happens over
there with those guys
secular people have displayed a similar
attitude of course the media and
Hollywood is always eager to spike the
football anytime the Catholic Church's
lands in hot water there they're always
eager to jump on that they're very
excited about it and they will usually
do so as insulting ly in degrading ly as
possible Trevor Noah
Trevor Noah for instance said yesterday
on the daily show that the Catholic
Church is now nothing but a quote
molesting Club with opening prayer which
is obviously a slam not just on the
bishops and priests responsible it's a
slam on all Catholics it's a saying that
that all Catholics are part of a
molesting Club now I find this
especially ironic coming from someone in
the Hollywood media world where child
rape and sex abuse are extremely and now
infamously common
I might even call Noah's industry a
molesting club with green screens can I
say that it's interesting to me that
Trevor net Trevor Noah has never
described Hollywood in the media in
those terms
has he no he saves that level of disgust
for the institutions that he is not
himself a part of as for the other
Christians who have been doing the
pharisee routine of thank you Lord that
I am NOT like them I should tell you
that your churches are not immune to
this far from it sex abuse is a very
serious problem in the evangelical world
and across all Protestant churches a
report that was a published a few years
ago from three of the companies that
ensure most of the Protestant churches
in the country revealed that they handle
around 260 abuse claims every year in
Protestant churches now if that average
holds year-to-year
that means the abuse problems in terms
of sheer numbers is actually worse in
Protestant churches than it is in the
Catholic Church that was actually the
opinion of a Liberty University law
professor and I think it's the grandson
of Billy Graham who said recently that
he thinks Protestant churches are worse
than Catholics at least when it comes to
responding to abuse claims
so at the very least what I'll say is
and the last thing I want to do is get
into a competition of your worse no
you're worse at sex abuse it there
simply is what I'll say is the point I'm
trying to make there simply is no
evidence and no reason to think that the
abuse situation is better in Protestant
churches
betting that in Catholic there's no
reason to think that no no no no
evidence none
I have heard from some people that this
is less of a problem Protestant churches
because those churches are don't have a
global mechanism by which to cover up
these crimes and that's true but that
doesn't mean they don't have a mechanism
even if the mechanism just is consist of
just one pastor who rules over the
church by himself and is accountable to
no one and so is in effect a sort of
little Pope unto himself in his church
well that's a mechanism there are many
cases of that a pastor he's accountable
no one in this church he abuses someone
well okay then the mechanism to cover it
up is pretty simple because he's the
only guy in charge or maybe the
mechanism is a is a church board or or
whatever the point is abusers will find
a way to exploit the circumstances no
matter the circumstances as an abuser
there are certain advantages that you
can exploit in the Catholic Church
environment there are certain advantages
that you can exploit in the Protestant
church environment okay it's it's it's
Changez either way so
we know it's a big problem in media and
Hollywood it's a big problem in the
churches Catholic and Protestant it's a
big problem in the sports world we think
of Penn State think of women's
gymnastics it's a problem in the medical
profession there was a recent report
that was published that found thousands
of case cases of physician sex abuse
across America the worst child molester
in history was a pediatrician in
Delaware he molested hundreds of
children's for years before he was
caught
and what about public schools
our school systems are crawling with sex
predators there was a study commissioned
by the Department of Education which
found that one in ten public school
students are targets of sexual
misconduct by teachers that works out to
over four million victims
and out of that number three million
have experienced actual sexual assault
so that's another million they've got
four million a million of that is you
know could be sexual harassment or some
other form and then three million
according to this report is is actual
sexual assault by teachers against
students
the epidemic in our schools
statistically is 100 times worse than it
is in the Catholic Church though it's
probably gotten about a hundred times
less media attention
um and that's just abuse by teachers
against students and then you have abuse
by students against other students which
is a problem unto itself
recently the AAP found 17 thousand cases
of student on student abuse in a four
year period
so you've got you've got one in ten
students who are victims of sexual
misconduct by teachers 17,000 cases of
student on student abuse just just to
put this in perspective the the
situation in Pennsylvania which is a
horrible situation and I've been railing
against it all week but in that case you
have I believe it's a thousand victims
something like 300 priests accused over
five or six decades which is still
terrible and awful and in demonic and
every word and you run out of adjectives
to describe it because it's so terrible
but even that does not represent the
kind of volume it doesn't come anywhere
near the kind of volume that you have in
the public schools so why aren't we
having a national conversation about
that why are we having a national
conversation about the crisis in our
schools why isn't anyone talking about
it I mean I I've talked about it many
times nobody cares
is that that's the incredible thing to
me about this issue know people care so
much about more about the Catholic
Church situation meanwhile most people
care about it they don't even go to
Catholic their kids are not you know
their kids are not threatened by priests
your if you send your kid to public
school
you should care about this it is
extremely common one in 10 students I
think that qualifies as extremely common
I think it does 17,000 cases I think
that qualifies as a huge problem if you
send your kids to public school how
could you not be focused on this how
could you be more focused on the
Catholic Church when you're setting your
kid into this environment for six hours
a day five days a week nine months a
year for thirteen years do you
understand the statistical probability
that he that he that he will be at the
very minimum sexually harassed by a
teacher
it is a
the problem the probability is
substantial let's put it that way so why
aren't we talking about and why is it
Trevor Noah describing the public school
system as a quote molesting club with
textbooks
so media Hollywood Catholic Church
Protestant Church sports medicine public
schools
I bring all this up not to minimize the
problem in the Catholic Church but to do
the opposite the point I'm trying to
establish is that the problem is much
bigger than the church I wish it was
just confined to the Catholic Church or
to some other institution
I wish most of all I could look at
Hollywood and say oh yes it just happens
in Hollywood you know cuz my kids are
never gonna be in Hollywood I'm never
gonna go to Hollywood and it's easy for
me to say oh yeah those de botched
perverts in Hollywood and there are a
lot of the botched perverts in Hollywood
but I wish I could say oh yeah it's all
happening there but I can't
the problem is much bigger than that and
if you're sitting off and thinking whoa
I'm a true I'm so glad I don't have to
worry about it because I'm not Catholic
well if you're thinking that you're a
fool
if you send your kid to public school if
you play sports and he goes to the
doctor if he's if he's in a youth group
at church you know how often you hear
about youth pastors molesting their 14
and 15 year old kids that are in their
charge you know office you know you know
how common that is
so if you send your kid into any of
those environments there is a real
possibility of abuse this is a disease
that infects the culture and every
institution is vulnerable to it every
institution
nobody is is exempt
the problem not only exists everywhere
it is really bad everywhere these other
institutions that I've mentioned it's
not like there have been a few cases
there it's there have been a ton of
cases in all of those institutions until
we start to see the problem in these
terms and still we until we stop acting
like this is a danger confined to places
where we don't go and we don't send our
children until we face the full reality
nothing will get better
that's the point I'm trying to make
that is it doesn't that that provides no
excuses whatsoever for any of these
particular institutions or anyone in
those institutions not at all and the
people who are it you know if you're in
a Protestant church you need to be
focused especially on what's going on
across on charges you're in the Catholic
Church
you'll be focused especially on that if
you if you are in Hollywood then you got
to be focused especially on that the
people in these institution have to be
looking within themselves in their own
ranks first
and then look without because it's so
easy to it's so easy I could sit here
all day railing against Hollywood and
and they deserve to be railed against
and it doesn't and of course we should
talk about it I'm not saying we should
never discuss it you know I'm not saying
if you're if you're not in Hollywood it
means you should never talk about it but
it's it's easy to do it's so easy you
know you risk nothing
it doesn't make you at all uncomfortable
because it's all about them it's the
other it's over there it's not me
so yeah we got to do some of that
because we all have to be holding each
other accountable
but if we're only doing that if we're
only looking without and we're never
looking within then we are only
contributing to the overall cultural
problem because that's a big part of the
reason why these these situations get so
bad within these institutions because
the people in the institutions do not
want to look within themselves and
they're always looking out there
now you may ask why is this problem so
prevalent
now that we've established it that it's
not so easy as saying oh yeah it's a
Catholic problem or oh it's a Protestant
problem or oh it's a Hollywood problem
now that we've established that and we
see how prevalent it is it creates a
whole new you know it creates a whole
new mystery of a very disturbing one
where we say how is this so common in
our culture
how how is this going on everywhere
well we know that at root
as Christians we know that this goes
back to the fall of man we are a fallen
species
and so these sins have always existed
ever since the fall of man and they
always will
but we can ask ourselves have they
always been this common
has it always been the case that every
institution in American culture is
riddled with abuse molestation rape etc
has that always been the case I guess
there's no way to know for sure we can't
it's hard you can't really look back
into into the past and quantify these
sorts of problems especially by the
nature of the problem means people doing
it or not going to exactly be keeping
records of what they did so it's hard to
know exactly but it certainly seems like
it's worse now
I would like to think that anyway I'd
hate to think that it's just always been
this way forever that it's always been
this bad forever because if that's the
case then you really think well it's an
it'll never get better there's it's like
and there's no problem there's no point
in even then even trying to make it
better because apparently it can never
be better but I don't think that's the
case
I do think it appears to be worse now
than in the past and I think that it is
I think that goes back to
general moral breakdown in our culture
kind of moral indifference they break
down of empathy which has led to this
moral indifference and when you have
when you've got
a breakdown in the kind of moral code
and then you have perversion and
debauchery hedonism that becomes more
prevalent and at the same time people
are becoming desensitized and
indifferent
unless able to see and recognize the
dignity in their fellow man and often
these things happen at the same time but
as they happen and as they get worse I
think of course you're gonna see more of
this
and when you read about these horrible
cases in any of these institutions but
talking specifically about the Catholic
Church you read about some of this these
things these priests were doing you see
not only that are these depraved
perverts but also they just have no they
just simply do not recognize the
humanity of anyone other than themselves
and so they can look at children and see
nothing but objects to be used for their
pleasure
and I think we see that more and more in
our culture where we we look at each
other even even people who aren't child
molesters I still think there is this
tendency among a lot of people to see
other people as just objects as not as
human beings but as objects to be used
to be exploited to be tossed to the side
whatever
and all of that I think leads us here
and if there is going to be any
improvement we all have to look
immediately around ourselves within our
own ranks and start there and then work
out from there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed